[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم الى برنامج نقاش على
الصدقه
الرئيس البرازيلي المنتخب عندما قال
للبرازيليين بامكان اليمين ان يقتل ورده
واثنتين وثلاثه لكنه لن يتمكن من منع قدوم
الربيع اليوم فرحه اليسار في البرازيل
وعموم دول ما يعرف بالمد الوردي لا
تضيعيها في الخوف كانت كبيره جدا القدره
على هزيمه مرشح اليمين المتطرف
واخراج اليمين الحاكم منذ عشر سنوات من
السلطه وفي الواقع فوز الاولى جاء بشق
الانفس وليس فوزا كبيرا فهو بالكاد حصل
على 50 فاصل 83% مقابل
49.7 10%
الولاده سيلفا بعد فوزه شدد فيها على حاجه
بلاده الى السلام والوحده
في البرازيل تشهد انقساما غير مسبوق وما
شراسه الحملات الانتخابيه الى الدليل على
ذلك فالى اي مدى ستكون مهمه لولا ده سيلفا
سهله في الحكم بعد ان حقق حلم الوصول الى
الرئاسه مجددا هو المضطر الى الحكم مع
كونجرس محافظ جدا ومؤيد لمول سونارو
للحديث عن ذلك نرحب بضيوف النقاش اليوم
الاستاذ ابراهيم السخاوي مدير مكتب جريده
الاهرام في البرازيل سابقا نرحب ايضا
بالاستاذ غسان احمر صحفي والمحلل السياسي
وبعلي فرحات الكاتب والصحفيه ونرحب ايضا
دي جانيرو اهلا بكم جميعا لكن دعونا قبل
ان نفتح النقاش ان نتحدث مع اشرف عبيده
الذي يتابع لنا منذ ايام الانتخابات
الرئاسيه في البرازيل همم اهلا بكم مشاهده
وان كان هناك الان بعض المعلومات التي
تقول بانه ممكن ان يتحدث
ويعلن موقفه في الواقع مرحبا
مرحبا كوزيت الاكيد الانتظارات كبيره
للبرازيليين وايضا المجتمع الدولي جير
بوليسينارو لم يتحدث منذ اعلان فوز الاولى
بالانتخابات الرئاسيه
البرازيليه هو الان بصدد عقد اجتماع مع
وزراء الاخبار تشير انهم من الممكن ان
يتحدث بعد هذا الاجتماع الوزير وبعض
الاخبار الاخرى تقول انه لن يتحدث مطلقا
يعني هناك غموض كبير جدا في الشارع وفي
قرار
همم عدم التحدث مباشره اما لتهنئه منافسه
لولا او استنكار نتائج هذه الانتخابات وهو
الذي شدد في حملته الانتخابيه ان كانت
النتائج متقاربه فانه يطعن في مصداقيتها
كان قد
انتقد التصويت الالكتروني انتقد عمليات
الانت البارحه مثلا رئيس شرطه المرور في
البرازيل قام بوضع حواجز تمنع تنقل
الحافلات في اتجاه المكاتب الاقتراع ما
دفع رئيسا اللجنه لجنه الانتخابات الى
المطالبه فورا بازاله هذه
الحواجز رئيس مركز شرطه المرور هو مقرب
بول سينار وكان قد اصدر في العديد من
المرات على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي دعوات
للتصويت لهذا الاخير اذا المشهد هنا منقسم
بشده بين احب جاري
يقولون ان العمليه الانتخابيه كانت مزوره
انه تم اختطاف الفوز منه بون سونار وانصار
ولو الفريحين بعودته همم اليسار الى سدته
الحكم من جديد والماده الوردي كما ذكرتي
كوزيت في امريكا اللاتينيه باستثناء ثلاثه
دول الباراغواي الاوروغواي وعليكم فان
بقيه الدول في امريكا التينيه يحكمها
احزاب من اليسار والفرحه كبيره خاصه بوصول
اكبر الدول الى صده الحكم اليسرى
عوده اليسار الى اكبر دول امريكا
اللاتينيه طيب همم اشرف قد نعود اليك في
حال صدر اي شيء في الواقع عن بولس سونار
او اي تفاصيل هامه تتعلق بموقفه من فوز
الاولى ده سيلفا همم استاذ غسان همم الفوز
كان صعب جدا همم يعني لو لا بالكاد حصل
على نقطه ونصف اكثر من بور سونار وبرايك
همم بنفس الوقت كيف نجح الاولى في انتظار
هذا الفوز
اذا استاذ غسان احمر
هل
[موسيقى]
استاذ غسان احمر معنا
او الاستاذ علي فرحان ربما
طيب يبدو انه ضيوفي على الاقل في البرازيل
لا يسمعونني بسبب غسان او استاذ علي فرحات
ان كان بالامكان تاكيد وصول صوت اليكما
نعم اسمعك بشكل واضح
متى ما هي العوامل برايك التي سمحت
هذا الفوز وان كان يعني فوز على شعره كما
يقال بالعاميه
في الولايات السابقه لكن هناك عده عوامل
اهم هذه
المسائل هي اولا التفاف عدد من النخب
البرازيليه ومن المثقفين وايضا التفاف
يمين الوسط الى جانب لولا وهو الذي يعني
اتى بنائب رئيس وهو جيرالدو التي من وهو
من يمين الوسط وايضا يمين الوسط لا يقل
عداءا لليمين المحافظ عن التيار اليسار
هذا اولا ثانيا هناك جمله من الاخطاء
ارتكبها فول سونار خلال حكمه اهمها همم
موضوع كورونا اداره عمليات كورونا مما ادى
الى وفاه
680,000 ضحيه كل الدراسات في البرازيل
تشير على انه لو كان هناك اداره سليمه ولو
كانت اللقاحات وصلت مبكرا الى البرازيل
نتفادت البرازيل كلوثيه هذا العدد بمعنى
انه يتحمل مسؤوليه هذه الضحايا بالاضافه
الى عدد من ملفات الفساد التي تطال نجليه
ادواردو
وهمم شراء عقارات بالمال الحي و همم ايضا
همم مخاطبه الرئيس البرازيلي وهذا اهم شيء
في الموضوع
للتياره
واستبعاد التيار الاخر لم يتعاطى كرئيس
لكل البرازيل بل تعاتك رئيس لجزء من
البرازيليين وضل يهاجم الجزء الاخر
ويتهممه بالشيوعيه والتخلف وما الى ذلك
ربما زخم جديد يعرفه اليسار ام اخطاء
مرعبه لبورسو
لا هي مزيج من من امرين لكن انا اقول لك
في البرازيل مثلا لو احسن بوسونار التصرف
لم استطاع اليسار العوده اليسار تعرض الى
حرب شعوذه الى ملفات فساد مختلقه والى
حمالات اعلاميه شرسه يعني طالت من اليسار
في البرازيل ولو ادار او احسن الاداره
لكان اليسار تاخر جدا في العوده الى
البرازيل الاستاذ غسان احمر
كيف كيف نجاح الاولى اليوم بتخطي يعني هذه
المعركه يعني غير مسبوقه بشراستها كيف كيف
تمكن من اجتياز نقول درب الجمله اتهامات
بالفساد السجن همم لاحقا تم اسقاطها من
الفساد لكنه لم يبرئ همم التره للتعامل مع
وزير للعدل هو نفس القاضي الذي حكم عليه
بالسجن همم
ما هي عوامل يعني همم العوامل التي سمحت
هذه النتيجه اليوم للانتخابات الرئاسيه في
البرازيل
[موسيقى]
الكرام اعتقد ان كل ما اتمنى
الاجابه ان يخفف التسلسل
البرازيل في حاله من الانقسام
ايضا الى خطاب رئيس البرلمان البرازيلي
ورئيس مجلس الذين طالبهم واطلبوا منهم ان
يتبع او ان يكون بخطاب يعود الروح السلميه
للشارع
ويحد من الانقسام
البرازيل تحتاج الى الوحده والسلام
منصور
الشاحنات الكبرى الان الوضع شده المتوفره
انا اتمنى ان ان ان ان ان ان يكون فوز
لولا
وسياسته ودبلوماسيته تقوده وتقود فريقه
الى اتباع النهج اقل حده وايضا لانجيبك
على سؤالك كيف فاز الاولى في هذه الفارق
الضعيف انا انا كشخصيا واا واعتقد بان
الذي ساعده اكثر هو عضو مجلس الشيوخ من
اصل لبناني همم التي تدعى همم
[موسيقى]
سيمون
ثابت هي التي فاضت اخذت معهم المرحله
الانتخابيه الاولى وفازت بالمركز الثالث
كان لها تقريبا 5.4 من المجموعه الاصوات
ولديها خطاب موجه تماما للعنصر اعتقد
بانها استطاعت الى حد كبير ان تجلب له نصف
هذه الاصوات والفارق اذا حسبناه لا يتجاوز
60 مليون صحه 30 مليون صوت اغتصبهم مع
الاصوات المؤيده له في الولايات الشماليه
الشرقيه الذي يقلقني في هذا الكون
سونار فاز في 15 ولايه هي التي تعتبر
منتجه
هي التي تستهلك اكثر
بعين الاعتبار يتبع النهج جدا
اقتصاد ونهجن بعيدا عن يساري المتطرفه
بانتظار ان يجهز ضيفنا في في القاهره
ابراهيم السخاوي ساعود اليك استاذ علي
فرحات اشار الاستاذ غسان احمر الى الجيش
همم
هل بالفعل هناك خطر اليوم في البرازيل بان
يتحرك الجيش او يقوم باي خطوه
بورسعيد الجيش
يعني هناك عده مغطات سوف نتكلم عنها اثناء
الحلقه لكن براي لا يستطيع الجيش
البرازيلي اتخاذ مثل هذا القرار
وتحدثت مصادر صحفيه مقربه من بطوله
كان قد فتح حوارا مع الجيش منذ فتره عندما
استشعر
الاستطلاعات التي كانت تعطي سيلفا
الارجيحيه وكان جواب القياده العسكريه
بالرفض الكامل لانها لن تستطيع القيام في
مثل هذا الامر نحن نعرف ان ده سيلفا اليوم
لحظه صحيح انه يحظى بنسبه طفيفه همم تزيد
عن نسبه همم لكن حين نتحدث عن الاحزاب
البرازيليه عن النخب البرازيليه عن
المثقفين وغيرهم لولا ده سيلبا همم يعني
همم لديه هذه المشروعيه عندما ننظر الان
الى الاعتراف
من قبل السياسيين البرازيليين حتى من بعض
النواب ومن بعض الشخصيات القريبه من بناره
مناسبه الوزراء الذي يجتمع معهم بنسونار
اليوم هم يديرون حوار معه
لمحاوله اقناعه بالاعتراف في ذا سلفا لان
تداعيات عدم الاعتراف خطيره على برشلونه
نفسه ولن تكون ذات اهميه على بنار لان فقط
صحح امرا واحدا جاء في السؤال وهو عدم كبر
الداخلي هذا الكلام يعني دائما كان يردده
بوسونار همم في همم ملفات الكيك نيوز لولا
ده سيلفا بر نعم لان الملفات فقط
العام وقاضي التحقيق قد سرب التسريبات
الاتصالات واكدت هذه التسريبات انهم كانوا
يقومون بدعوه كيديه سياسيه لازاحه هذه
امور كشف عنها موقع
هي مسجله وموفقه وسقوط هذه التهم هي تبرقه
اوتوماتيكيه لداسي الباب بدليل واحد ان
ال- الهيئه العليا للانتخابات سمحت له
بالترشح ولو كان هناك اي شبهه في هذا
الامر لا منع من الترشح للانتخابات
الرئاسيه
المحكمه التي حكمت على دوله
مدينه القدس
بالنسبه للمحكمه الدستوريه العليا هي هي
ليست المخوله في اصدار الحكم ومحاكمه
المخوله في البرازيليه لذلك اسقرت جميع
الاحكام واسقطه التعاون ولذلك تم التبريته
لاحقا ولكن ليست تمريته من الاحكام انا
اعتقد انها اذا كان هناك في عوده الى
الماضي لن تفيدنا الان بشيء النجوم الان
اعتقد بان دون الاسير فارس
حضرتك حضرتك موجود بالبرازيل الاستاذ علي
همم من المفيد ربما العوده الى بعض النقاط
التي توضح اكثر للمشاهد عن عن ماذا عن
ماذا نتحدث على اي حال ادعونا نشرك لانه
تاخرنا كثير على الاستاذ ابراهيم السخاوي
مدير مكتب جريده الاهرام في البرازيل
سابقا استاذ ابراهيم هل مفاجئ ان يعود
اليسار اليوم الى الحكم في همم في
البرازيل وايضا ان ان ان ان تشهد امريكا
اللاتينيه عوده ما يعرف بالمد الوردي
اخي الكريم الدكتور غسان في في صوباولو
بمكتبه وتوقعنا او ان توقعت فوز او عوده
لوردس سيلفا في حال خروجه من السجن الان
عاده الرايات الحمر لتطوف شارع باوليستا
في صوباولو وساحه السلطات الثلاث في
البرازيليه من باراناها الى الى سيدي
وبهيه ومن ريسيفر جانيرو وشمال البرازيل
عاد حزب العمال بقوه
واحتفل انصاره في كل الميادين واحتفلت
ايضا ال- ال-
المتعاطفين مع حزب العمال في دول امريكا
اللاتينيه في الارجنتين و كوبا وفنزويلا
وبوليفيا وغيرها من الدول
اعتقد انه يعني اول ليس امرا ااا لم يكن
راي المتفائلا بقدر ما هو احساس على الارض
في فتره عشت فيها وسط الشعب البرازيلي
واعرف جيدا ما يطمح اليه وكيف وماذا فعل
لولا ده سيلفا من اجل الشعب البرازيلي
هناك مقوله برازيليه شهيره كان يعتمدها
الاولاد سيلفا دائما وان
وبرازيل ومباريس مراسيل
البرازيل البلد دائما يستحق الافضل لولا
ده سيلفا ااه كانت له انجازات عظيمه على
كل المستويات سواء مصطفى الاقتصادي
والاجتماعي من برامج الدعم الاجتماعي
البورصه فاميليا لبرنامج فوميزير وتصفير
ال- ال- الفقر له همم طفره كبيره في مجال
الصحه واستدعاء وهمم واطباء من كوبا افضل
اطباء في امريكا اللاتينيه حوالي خمس اا
50,000 طبيب تقريبا انجازاته في بالتعليم
همم
ايضا فكره
انا اركز على
موضوع اليسار كما كنا شاهدنا في فتره
سابقه يعني تقريبا كل الامريكا اللاتينيه
باستثناء بعض الدول كانت تحت حكم اليسار
اذا اليوم البرازيليون اختاروا لولا همم
لانه اليسار لم يستطيع ان يخرق عندما كان
الاولى همم في السجن
همم
اليسار قال له دور طبعا في عوده الاولى
ولكن الشعب البرازيلي لم يكن له خيار
والولد سيلفا همم كل المرشحين الاخرين همم
اليمين اليمين البرازيلي حشرت كله انصاره
همم وراء بورسونارو واليسار
البرازيلي حصل كل الانصاري وهذا ما عبرت
عنه النتيجه همم يعني فاصل تسعه من عشره
تقريبا في نزوله بالاضافه الى كمل اصوات
الباطله كثيره جدا همم هناك عده عوامل ادت
الى هذا الانقسام منها عدم اهتمام الى
المرشحين بقضايا مهمه جدا وحيويه للشعب
البرازيلي مثل التعليم والصحه همم كلا
للمرشحين استخدم العنف لفظ تجاه الاخر
وكان هناك بعض المناوشات بين ال- ال-
الجماهير ال- همم
او همم مؤيد المرشحين همم وصلت الى بعض
ال- ال- الخلافات المسلحه ال- ال-
المقاوشات المسلحه احيانا ولكن اعتقد قادر
على توحيد البرازيل مره اخرى مثل ما وحدها
من قبل همم بالمناسبه الانقسام اللي حاصل
في الشارع البرازيلي لما يكن نتيجه هذه
الانتخابات ولكنه هناك جاء منذ همم الزق
بالولد سيفا الى السجن ومنذ عزل ديلما
روسيه في العزل البرلماني ومنذ الانتخابات
الماضيه مع فرناندو الحداد وبروسينو
همم الى اي مدى محمد همم
لولا ده سيلفا سهله ستكون في الحكم يعني
هو اليوم نجح في تحقيق حلم العوده الى
الحكم لكن هل بدا اليوم كابوس الحكم سيبدا
ان همم انه سيحكم في الواقع مع
خصوم كثيرين
الدور الاول الانتخابات انتهى والدور
الثاني منتخب انتهى اعتقد ان هناك اعلان
الدور الثالث الدور الثالث سيكون مقرره
البرلمان ومجلس الشيوخ وحكام الولايات
الاخرى كيف سيخين نسيج التحالف دون بين
برلمان لا يملك كتلته
[موسيقى]
الكبرى وكيف سيخين تفاهم وتحالفات مع
اعضاء مجلس الشيوخ الاغلبيه
هذه اعتقد هي اكبر صوبات سيتخاها الولد
سيلفا انا اعتقد باليقين لانه يملك
دبلوماسيه فائقه في المفاوضات السياسيه
ليست مساله يعني خلاف سياسي اما انا مخطئه
بين بورسونارو وجيولوجيه بورسونارو المكان
الذي دفع اليه البرازيل وبين بالنهايه
سيلفا نقابه رئيسيه ساري سابق
عمليا هناك على مستوى الايديولوجيا شيء
مختلف او خلاف
متابعه 30 عاما السياسه البرازيليه يوم
بيوم لا ارى ان هناك يمين متطرقه في
البرازيل الا مع وصول فول سونار الحكم
الشعب البرازيلي طبيعته ثقافته لا تسمح
بشكل من الاشكال ان يكون جميل متطرفه الذي
غز هذه المعركه الطائفيه هو وصول فول
سونار وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي التي
ادارها ابنائه الاسلام واحد عضو مجلس
الشيوخ والثاني ليس هناك من متطرفه وليس
هناك فلوقات بيولوجيه داخل البرلمان كبيره
طبعا الان موجوده لان الشارع من قصد ولكن
اعتقد والسلطتين ان تسجل ذلك على الانسان
خلال السته اشهر القادمه
سيتخطى كل هذه البيولوجيا لانه لا يوجد في
عقليه مواطن البرازيلي والسياسي البرازيلي
يمين المتطرفا قد تجدين اليمين المتطرف في
بعض الدول الاوروبيه ولكن في امريكا
اللاتينيه جرب فقط مره في كولومبيا جربت
حظها مع الجميل المتطرف ولم يكن متطرفه
كثيرا
ذلك ان لولا لن يعود الى اليسار الذي قال
لي لولا ستقولين يوم اصبح من يسار الوسط
قد يكون لديك حق لانه لولا ايضا يتراجع عن
مسائل ربما اساسيه في ملفات اساسيه لليسار
فيما يتعلق ربما بحق الاجهاض همم
بعد الفوز مباشره وعند القائمه الفوز في
الفندق الذي يجت فيه الكول تستطيعين
تشاهدي ان الرايه العلم البرازيلي كانت في
الخلف ولم يرفع احد من متابعيه في داخل
الصاله عالم حزب العمال انا واكد لك ان
الولد سيلفا سيكون يسارا وسطك
وستقول وزارته وسياسه الدوليه سيقوده
سيلثامورين وسلسو مورين سيكون كما قاد
خلال سنوات سياسه خارجيه برازيليه ستستطيع
ان تبقي تحالفات مع عدد كبير من دول
امريكا الجنوبيه واوروبا وامريكا الشماليه
هلا تعتقد بانه الاولاد دا سيلفا ربما همم
تعلم الكثير في هذه العوامل التي قضاها
بين الحكم وبين السجن وبين حفله انتخابيه
همم تعلم ربما ان
يهذب النزع اليسريه لديه
في البرازيل منه 25 عاما وعملته كمراسل
على الارض انا لم ارى في حياتي
لم يكن هذا الامر ابدا يمكن كان هذا الامر
عندما كان نقيبا للحدادين اثناء ثورته على
الانقلاب العسكري لولا ده سلبه هو شخصيه
ااه ديناميكيه برغماتيه يتحدث مع جميع
فئات المجتمع البرازيلي وبالمناسبه اريد
ان اتحدث عن الخارطه السياسيه الداخليه في
البرازيل هناك امر من لا يعيش في البرازيل
لا يدركه وهي مشكله كانت مشكله وحل في نفس
الوقت كانت تعاني منه البرازيل ما يسمى
بامفيدي لداده يعني اللا امام الحزبيه هذا
يعني بشكل كامل ان عدد كبير من النواب ومن
اعضاء مجلس الشيوخ يمكن ان ينتقل من مكان
الى مكان عندما تتغير الظروف السياسيه
وهذا ما يراهن عليه دولاب الان رو جومايا
رئيس المجلس التشريعي السابق يقول انه
بالحسابات لا يوجد اكثريه لبل سونار
واليمين المحافظ في المجلسين هناك عدد
وازن ليمين الوسط المتحالف معلولا داسيلبا
هذه ظاهره جديده ظاهره يبنى عليها في كل
امريكا اللاتينيه حكم اليسار الخالص وحكم
اليمين الخالص اثبت فشله بشكل كامل الذي
اثبت نجاحه هو التعاون ما بين الطرفين
ويعني قطع ال- ال- الفرص امام اليمين
المتطرف او حتى اليسار المتطرف للتحكم في
البلاد اعتقد ان البرازيل الان امام
تحديات صعبه جدا اهم هذه التحديات هو خلق
حوار كامل مع المؤسسه العسكريه في البدايه
المؤسسه العسكريه اعطت اشارات ايجابيه
ثانيا والاهم مع الكنائس الانجيليه التي
كانت في المره الماضيه وهي التي انشات هذا
الخطاب الديني المتطرف تخيل لسيدتي ان
احدى اعضاء مجلس الشيوخ وهي تنتمي الى
الطائفه الانجيليه قد تم التبرع منها من
قبل الكنائس الانجيليه لانها ايدت سلمى
ايضا تخيلي ان النائب كارلا زمبيلا اطلقت
النار في ساو باولو على همم احد الاشخاص
حينما ردد شعار مضاد بحزبها وتخيل ايضا ان
النائب السابق روبرت روبرتو جيفرسون اطلق
النار على الشرطه الفيدراليه وشرحها شخصيا
ثقافه العنف هذه اتت من مجبل الخطابات
الدينيه التحضيريه
استاذ علي
الحملات الانتخابيه وكنت شاهدها وكنت اذهب
الى الشارع ارى صورتين المرشحين جنبا الى
جنب انا في جنوب البرازيل حيث هنا اكثريه
شعبيه
كلبه في احد المناطق هذا لم نشهد في
البرازيل الا في الثماني سنوات في الاربع
سنوات الماضيه وفي هذه السنه
بالعوده الى موقف بول سونار واستاذ
ابراهيم امم برايك هذا الصمت بعد ساعات
طويله من اعلان الفوز هذا اصمت لبلسونار
لماذا يمهد هل هل هل هل يمكن ان نشهد يعني
حاله ترامبيه في البرازيل مثلا همم هل
يمكن ان يكون همم
همم لا اظن اعتقد ان مثل كل الانتخابات هي
بعض المناوشات التي
تفرزها الاعلان فوز مرشح اخر ولكن العالم
كله يعني معظم رؤساء العالم منها همم
جمبايدر الرئيس الامريكي ورئيس الفرنسي
ومعظم الرؤساء والنهارده النهارده
النهارده الرئيس السيسي هنا الرئيس الاولى
ودعاه لحضور قمه المناخ في شرم الشيخ
اعتقد الاعتراف العالمي والشرعيه الاولى
التي لا شك فيها سوف تهدا الامور خلال
ايام على ما اعتقد الشعب البرازيلي بطبعه
شعب ابو سالم وليس شعب عنيف ولكن هو شعب
حماسي وهناك الفرق بين الحماس والعنف يعني
همم بس عايز اضيف نقطه على كلام الدكتور
غسان وتضيف الكريم انه همم لولا السلف لم
يكن ابدا عنصريه بالعكس بقى همم اشعار
والحريه والمساواه والعداله وعدم التمييز
وحقوق الانسان وح في المراه لولا سيلفا
قدم نموذج متفرد ومتميز في نظام الحكم
الديمقراطيه التشاركيه
واعتقد يعني لو تفتكروا معي او تتذكر معي
ان لولا دي سيلفا همم بعد نجاحي في اكتوبر
2002 في انتخابات البرازيليه في الفتره
الاولى كان اول لقاء كان مع رجال المال
والاقتصاد والاعمال الراسماليين وقال لهم
انا اشتراكي وجئتم همم وجيت لاعلمكم
الراسماليه لولا السيل بقى في الفتره
الثانيه همم عندما انتهت مدته كان من اكبر
الداعمين لاستمرار وتغيير ودعوه الى تغيير
الدستور الراسماليين استفاده استفاده عظمى
يقول له قدم نموذج رائع في ربط راس المال
بخدمه المجتمع همم بالاضافه الى سياسه
خارجيه متميزه وكانت البرازيل رائده في
امريكا اللاتينيه عن طريق سيلفي وامورين
من همم المفكر الكبير وزير خارجيه
البرازيل في عهد الاولى ثم وزير الخارجيه
والدفاع
وزير الدفاع في عهد دلما في الفتره الاولى
همم قدم نموذج في الدبلوماسيه التوازن
الناعم البرازيل قدمت نموذج في في في في
في التفاعل الضوء يعني قدمت نفسها في عهد
الاولى كدوله فاعله في النظام الدولي
اللون ده سيلفا اسيا يعني كان مؤسسين
تحالف الاناصور اللي دول البريكس كمادول
البركس اللي هو الان كل الدول تتمنى
الانضمام له واعتقني للول هياخذ اجراءات
بدعوه بعض الدول انضمام لبركس بلاستي
سيلفا سوف يفتح شبه اكثر موضوع
لان البرنامج لم يعد متوازنا همم بالمره
ههه الجميع معجب بالولاده سيلفا همم
فبالتالي همم دعنا ننتقد قليلا ان الولاده
سلفا اه طيب همم لا ده سيلفا استاذ غسان
همم
يقول بانه همم بورسونارو تسبب ب ب بنابز
او بجعل البرازيل منبوذه همم اليس هذا
اليس في ذلك مبالغه كبيره
[ضحك]
الحقيقه بوسنار وكان عسوله على الصعيد
السياسي الدوليه يعني تماما كان معزوله
تصوري ان اليوم نحن نتكلم الان والرئيس
الاولى اجتمع والرئيس الارجنتيني والرئيس
الارجواي الان في سامبول
شهرين ثلاثه
يعرف تماما كيف هي الدبلوماسيه ولا يرفع
تماما مرجعيه العسكري خرج 27 سنه كنائب
برلماني كان يتحدث زملائه ويعمل يعني
الحقيقه الكثير من المشاكل انسان عن جهل
واعتقد ان ما اوصل رؤوسنار الى الحكم الى
سده الرئاسه هو فساد حسب العمال وهنا اقول
لك حزب العمال حزب العمال انا لا استطيع
يعني
شاهدتها على التلفزه
وكلنا نتبعناها يوم بيوم والذي اوصل لولد
سيلفا الى سده الرئاسه من جديد هو عن
جهينه وتطرف بسرعه
اخر اخر قتيل لها هو بور سونارو
ليس هذا سبب الرئيسي همم
لا يعرف تماما او لم يعرف تماما كيف
يتعامل مع الجائحه يعني كانت له تصريحات
الحقيقه تصريحات جاهل يعني لا يمكن لرئيس
دوله ان يتكون فيها اعتقد بان همم اخفاء
في في معالجه الوضع مع كفيف جدا
في المنظرات كثيره
وكان احد من الاسباب الاساسيه التي نبه
الفكر
لان بورسلان فعلا تسبب في موت الالات من
الناس لو لم يكن نتاخر في السيره اللقاحات
يعني هذا الشيء كمان معروف لا يمكن ان ان
يتجاوزه مهما كان يكون ولكن بقى له نتحدث
عن فساد حسب العمال الذي اساء كثيرا للولا
في لحظه من لحظات ايضا في الحملات
الانتخابيه وهنا اتوجع في سؤال الاستاذ
علي فرحات في الحملات اللي انت غبيه
شاهدنا بانه لم يعد هناك حرما همم بين بين
الفريقين يعني ايضا
همم ربما همم سقط في في في في مكان ما همم
بشكل مزعج يعني عندما راحوا يتهمون همم
بورسونارو بانه ياكل لحوم البشر او حتى
التلميح الى مساله انه همم يعني همم
متحرش بالاطفال او همم
اليس كذلك
نعم يعني هنا في الحقيقه اذا كنا موضوعيين
جايين بالسوناروا فرض اجند من الشتائم على
حزب العمال ووقع فيها وفي اول مناظره في
الجوله الثانيه استطاع بهذه
الاستفزازات ان يوقع دا سيلفا في المرحله
الثالثه حيث كان يتصدر داسي المرحله
الاولى عندما هزمه بالقطار حول جائزه
كورونا وايضا اما في الثالثه فقد استطاع
استطاع ان يستفزه وبالتالي لجاوله الى نقص
العبارات التي وهو غير معروف عنه
معروف عنه بانه قبل البرازيل همم دائما
يعني يقول بانه يحترم العائله البرازيليه
ويحترم الشعب البرازيلي لكن جره الى مثل
هذا الامر الاكثر من ذلك حتى على مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي وحتى بالشعارات بالامس
همم طالما اردت الانتقاد ونحن هنا في مجال
موضوع ليس في مجال تحيز بالام كنت انا في
الشارع ورايت بعض الشعارات التي يطلقها
انصار لولا دا سيلفا شعارات غريبه عجيبه
هي نفس الشعارات التي يطلقها اليمين
المتطرف وبالتالي للاسف الشديد تعلم او
اخذ الشارع الموالي لتسيبا موبيقات شارع
منصور وبالتالي كان هنا مكمل الخطوره في
البرازيل
شهاده العلاقه
البرازيل قد تشهد بالفعل عنفا ما
بمعزل عن اعتراف برسونار وبالهزيمه ام لا
نعم يعني هذه هي مهمه سيفا اليوم مهمه
مختلفه عن المهمات السابقه عليها اولا ان
يمد اليد الى النصف الاخر وان يتحدث ايضا
عن الشؤون العائليه يعني البرازيليون
يطوقون الى القيم العائليه اليسار في
امريكا اللاتينيه اخطا حينما حمل شعارات
يعني لا تفيد ولا تسمم من جوع هذه
الشعارات مثل الاجهاض ومع انهم يعني تخلوا
عنها ومع مثلا المثليه الجنسيه المتحرره
وغيرها لا اصابت فيهم مقتلا في البرازيل
وبالتالي على الولد ده سيلفا ان يعيد
صياغه الثقافه الداخليه السياسيه
وازاله الهواجس لدى ال 50% الاخرين من
الشعب البرازيلي وبالتالي هنا يستطيع ان
ينجح لكن يحتاج الى عمل دؤوب وطويل ويحتاج
الى شراكه من معظم البرازيليين داخل
الحكومه لا يمكن لهذه الحكومه ان تكون
ياساريه وهنا اا يعني لدينا معلومات ااا
موثوقه عن ان داسيلبا خلال 4 ايام سيشكل
فريق عمله وسيكون متنوعا من كافه الاطراف
السياسيه والمشارب السياسيه في البرازيل
باستثناء اليمين المتطرف طبعا
سيكون حاضرا في هذه التوليفه الحكوميه
استاذ علي بشكل واضح
وايضا فرناندو امريكي
عده شخصيات سيمون ثابت سيموني ثابت كانت
تواجه ذا سيلفا في المناظرات الانتخابيه
بشاراسه ومشروعه وهي قالت بكل صراحه انا
اختلف معلولا ده سيلفا في كثير من القضايا
لكن عندما هددت البرازيل الديمقراطيتها
وهويتها انا اقف مع دا سيلفا ولا يمكن ان
اقف وقوف المتفرج بالاضافه الى علاج
هم اسقطوا دا سيلفا في وقت من الاوقات
اعلنوا صراحه تائيده لانهم قالوا ان الوطن
بخطر
وتداول الديمقراطيه في قطر
ابراهيم السخاوي لنتحدث عن المواقف
الدوليه استاذ ابراهيم
كبير جدا بفوز الاولاد سيلفا وبالفعل يعني
الرئيس الامريكي كان من اول المهنيين قال
انه يتطلع الى العمل مع الاولى للتعاون
بين البلدين نفس الموقوف صدر عن الرئيس
الروسي قالت انها مستعده للارتقاء
بالشراكه الاستراتيجيه مع البرازيل الى
مستوى اعلى رئيس الفرنسي همم قال ان ال-
ال- الانتخابات في البرازيل
معها تبدا مرحله تاريخيه جديده في ال- في
البرازيل واا كتب لي لولا يقول معا سن
واحد جهودنا لمواجهه التحديات كثيره
المشتركه وتجديد تش اواصل الصداقه بين
بلدين ما الذي تفهمه من انه ليس فقط ترحيب
من اختيار هذه المفردات في همم التهنئه
التي يتوح بها هؤلاء القاده الى الولاده
سلفا
همم
مثل ما ذكرته منذ قليل ان البرازيل بلد
يتمتع بدبلوماسيه التوازن الناعم على قد
طيبه مع كافه الاطراف همم البرازيل دائما
تشارك في كل المنتديات الدوليه وتدعم كل
همم ما يحقق السلم والامن الدولي البرازيل
ايضا دوله فاعله في النظام الدولي اا
توسطت في كثير من الخلافات ايه بين الدول
كان اخر ملف تتدخل فيه لولا مثلا بالوساطه
الملف النوعي والايراني همم البرازيل
علاقتها متميزه بكل دول العالم
واوروبا فرنسا
واعتقد ان ترحيب الامريكي هو هو الذي يلفت
الانتباه اكثر همم
لانه همم
الولايات المتحده كانت تدعم في الانتخابات
السابقه والحاليه كان هناك بعض الاتجاهات
المدعيمه
نعم همم وبالتالي اعتقد ترحيب همم
ترحيب ماكرون مثل ما رحب كله رؤساء العالم
همم
لولا ده سيلفا لولا سيلفا همم من خلال
مستشاري خاصه السيسي عمريم همم عندما كتب
في 2010 عن الاقليميه الجديده ان النظام
الدولي لن يستمر كما هو همم وانه لن يعود
لن ينفرد قطب واحد بحكم العالم ولن يكون
هناك قطبين او ثلاثه ستكون هناك تكتلات
متعدده او قوه اقليميه متعدده همم الولد
سيلفا ااه اسس لهذا لما يطمح اليه من خلال
التجمعات التي تشارك فيها البرازيل مثل
الكسور وتجمع دول البريكس
همم دوري برازيلي فاعل في جي 20 في مجموعه
العشرين البرازيل بلد
يعني عظيم يعني اقتصاده متطور وعنده وعنده
الولد سيلفا يعني اعتقد المرحله القادمه
سيعمل على عدم جعل البرازيل فقط مخزن
للمواد الخام تتطور اقتصاديا البرازيل من
اكثر الدول انتاجا للحوم والدواجن والحبوب
البرازيل تقريبا بها همم سيلفا يهتم
بقضايا المناخ وهزيمه معظم دول العالم قسم
امريكا وفرنسا ومصر وغيرها همم
تعهد الحفاظ على غابات الامازون وعدم همم
جر البرازيل اللي تصحر للحفاظ على حكايه
لانقامات الامازون تمثل رئاسه العالم همم
همم لولا دي سيلفا اعتقد يعود مره اخرى
همم لولا ولكن بشكل جديد اكثر تسامح اكثر
حرصا على بلاده همم اكثر طموحا همم بجانب
البرازيلندا
هل سيسامح له لادا سيلفا نيمار على دعمه
بورسونارو
سيكون المسيح المنتظر والمخلص الذي ينقذ
البرازيل الاولى له مزاياه وله مساويه
اخفق واصابه زي او زي اي سياده الثاني لا
استطيع ان اجعل منه ك- ك- ظاهره لم تتركها
اليسا تبع بولونيا هو يكررها واتمنى ان هو
يستطيع خلال السنوات الاربعه لان اعتقد
بان ستكون اخر سنوات اربعه له في الحكم
اتمنى ان يستطيع ان يعيد للبرازيل وحدته
ولا اتمنى
ههه بالنسبه للعالم العربي استاذ علي همم
هل همم عوده اليسار بهذا الشكل الى
العدد دول في امريكا اللاتينيه هو خبر جيد
خصوصا بانه مثلا مع برشلونه وراينا مواقف
بما يتعلق بالقضيه الفلسطينيه همم ليست
لصالح الفلسطينيه
كان هناك استفزا ليس لها اي طعم يعني مثلا
زوجه بون سونار السيده الاولى تذهب الى
الانتخابات
عليه العلم الاسرائيلي ماذا تريد ان تقول
من هذا الامر ثم يقول انه سينقل السفاره
من تل ابيب الى القدس لماذا يعني البرازيل
دائما تتميز بعلاقاتها الطيبه والجيده مع
العالم العربي وهي تبيع العالم العربي
الكثير من ال- ال- اللحوم والبضائع وما
الى ذلك وايضا العرب يحبون البرازيل على
المستوى المعنوي مثلا في كره القدم يحبون
زياره البرازيل وسياحه في البرازيل
وينظرون الى البرازيل كانها دوله مشابهه
دوله قريبه والشعب البرازيلي ايضا يعبر في
مضمونه عن هذا الامر ماذا حصل الان يعني
جرير ارتكب خطيئه كبرى بحق البرازيل في
علاقاتها الدوليه في نسيجها الاجتماع
حينما يردد دائما المسيحيه المسيحيه من
يهجم على المسيحيه في البرازيل 90% من
البرازيليين هم من المسيحيين الكاثوليك
المعتدلين والذين يتبعون الى الكنيسه في
روما ثم ماذا عن الاديان الاخرى في
البرازيل لماذا يعني همم لعل بني سونار
لديه نوايا ايجابيه في داخلهم لكنه لم
يستطع ان يبرزها بل ابرز خطابا دمويه بين
قوسين بالنسبه للاخرين وبالتالي خسر
العالم العربي وخسر امريكا اللاتينيه خسر
خسر كل هذا الامتداد في امريكا اللاتي
معك استاذ علي فرحات هذا النقاش شكرا لك
علي فرحه الكاتب الصحفي اشكرك ايضا اصبح
السياسي غسان احمر واشكر الاستاذ ابراهيم
السخاوي مدير مكتب جريده الاهرام في
البرازيل سابقا شكرا لكم جميعا شكرا
لمشاهدين همم والى فقام
[موسيقى]